that should play me in a movie
adaptation of my life anyway
i mean
egotists that i am i'd happily play
myself
that'd solve any casting issues right
[Music]
hey there folks so it's time for another
conversation about the representation of
lgbtq plus
individuals in media and this time i'm
going to be talking about
trans individuals
specifically and more than that i'm
going to be stepping outside of what i
usually do because normally i tend to
frame these conversations through
points of reference that are kind of
relevant to the standard topics of this
channel i'll talk about your
representation in comic books in geek
media when
representation finally shows up on
things like star trek or
the marvel cinematic universe or what
have you i'll tend to latch onto those
kinds of things but this time i don't
want this to really be drama specific
this time
i want to talk about the patterns that
exist
in the films and i'm mostly going to be
talking about film i'll explain why in a
moment
that
depict
trans people
as the lead character and the primary
story being told and i want to look at
that specifically because what i'm going
to talk be talking about is not
as prevalent when we are talking about
secondary characters
and is not quite as much of an issue on
tv
and that is just
the framing and the decision of what is
worth telling about a transgender
person's story
so the reason i am largely avoiding
television and am focusing on ones where
the trans person can be said to be the
primary character of the film is because
i think it is very telling and
has led to some of the issues in
the discourse
the fact that
there seems to be a fairing fairly
narrow prescription to the idea of what
a trans story is
and that doesn't affect supporting
characters nearly as much because
while they may appear in anybody's story
it is not necessarily their story and
despite what some outraged merchants
would say the mere presence of a trans
person doesn't suddenly make it a trans
story
so
there's that and then in regards to
television
i should make note of this more often
than i do
television is actually often at least a
little bit ahead of major movies in
terms of representation in general and i
think a lot of that just has to do with
the money involved television just has
less money spent on it and as a result
is a medium where people are far more
likely to give a chance to a newer idea
or a newer face it's why you get a lot
more hey i've never seen that person
before in a leading role in a tv show
than you do in film there are fewer
films put out per year and a lot more
money spent out on them the age of
streaming even before the age of
streaming the amount of content we need
to fill channels and fill streaming
services demands a lot of stuff get made
and that they not spend too much money
on most of it so they take a lot more
chances
but as i said i want to focus on film
here because regardless of whether or
not things are better in tv and with
most of the stuff i talk about it
usually is
that is also something that is not
always as especially at this point not
always as good of a gauge of where sort
of the pop culture understanding of
something is
because the since tv has become so niche
and so micro targeted
it can very often happen these days that
a show can be a huge hit with a very
specific audience that the main
sharmanis literally has never heard of
the dang thing
that didn't always
used to be the case
back before
you know there were a million channels
and certainly long before streaming when
there were only three and eventually
four main channels on television and
then if you had cable it was a different
ball game
it used to be more ubiquitous what the
television experience was that's not the
case now
but with film
if the money is being put into it by a
major studio and i'm not really going to
be dealing with independence because
again with an independent film less
money is involved usually it's a
different ball game some of the movies i
will bring up are independently financed
but by and large when i talk about film
i'm talking about the mainstream
film
and the mainstream audience because that
is aimed at as many people as possible
and therefore is generally constructed
in a way is to be digestible to as many
people as possible and what these
filmmakers and studios believe will be
digestible about a trans story
to an audience
i think is
telling and worth
picking over now the first thing i want
to start by pointing out is that
almost
to a film
these sorts of movies and i'll list you
some examples
focus on the transition itself
usually from male to female because for
some reason movies like to do trans
feminine stories more but they will
focus on that transition as the actual
narrative
so for this we are talking about films
like the danish girl
transamerica breakfast on pluto a
fantastic woman boys don't cry
stories where the transition is either
the narrative itself or the impact of
the transition on the people around them
is the narrative
so whether it be directly because we're
actually watching
this person go through that transition
period like with the danish girl or
indirectly because we are watching the
impact that the transition has had
directly on their lives and the people
around them like with transamerica
it is putting the transition itself the
fact that this character is trans front
and center as the
thing
now that might make a lot of logical
sense like it's a trans story why
wouldn't the transition
be what you focus on
it does make a certain amount of sense
but
think about stories about other
groups other minorities
usually at least if they're good
they'll be about more than just
being that thing
so take for example
the film hidden figures excellent film
about real life people which
many of the
the trans stories that we're talking
about also are
but it is an amazing story and
if someone were to describe that film as
a movie about
black women navigating through life in
the 1960s
that would not be an accurate
but it would be very incomplete
because yes that's there and that has an
impact on the story being told but it's
about
their place at nasa
it's about them earning their place in
mathematics
and being recognized for their brains
so to say that it's just about them
being black women in that time period
that's like okay yeah but it's about a
lot more than that
and it might have been an interesting
story to tell even if that was not the
case even if it was a story about just
people who were doing the calculation
because that's well that's about what
half of a movie like apollo 13 is you
still could have had an interesting
movie but that
new thing that new element which again
is a real life thing
but that additional element
gives it
more interest but the story would still
be interesting at least to some degree
anyways
but with trans stories
that's kind of where it starts and ends
it's a story about
being trans
not
being trans while
accomplishing something else
but about being trans
or trying to transition
so
that's the first thing
now why do i feel that this is an issue
and as i pretty much always say when i
talk about patterns and tropes in
storytelling this is not on purpose
nobody's doing this deliberately nobody
has a master plan to try and control the
way we think about trans people but
these are still the patterns and i am
not condemning any individual film
filmmaker actor etc
as i go through this i'm just talking
about the storytelling patterns
so why is the centering
of
just being trans
basically every time a trans character
is the lead character of a story why is
that a problem
i mean
maybe it's
not showing as full of things as
possible but like can't that still be
good
well to a certain extent yes i mean more
trans representation in general and
presenting it in a way that focuses on
the thing that is going to be
the most confusing or unlike the
experience of many members of the
audience is not inherently a bad thing
but when that's what happens over and
over and over again and when that's
basically the only story that gets told
when trans people
are the lead characters
well then it frames our transition
as being the most important thing we
ever do
and the central
pillar of our entire lives
and perhaps for some of us it is
but as someone who
is a parent
who has
published a novel who
has other writing ambitions who tried to
get into acting
i have a lot of things
that are
just as important
to my life and to my development to my
being who i am and things that i hope to
accomplish
as the fact that i'm trans now the fact
that i'm trans is one of the most
immediately visible things
certainly
but
it can really
narrow the idea of what a trans person
is
and i would not be surprised if that
helps contribute to the sensibilities
of people who push back and say well all
you talk about is being trans everything
in your life is about being trans
no
it's not
but
a decent amount of the media that
depicts us especially putting us front
and center where we are meant to be
empathized with
it is framing us as though everything
about our lives is being trans and that
at this particular point in time
especially
uh is not super helpful
and there's another problem and this has
to do with sort of a lot of these
filmmakers and creators understanding of
what it means to be trans because it's
worth pointing out that
none of the films i mentioned and
virtually none of these stories overall
are being made by
trans creators
the
actors playing the roles weren't trans
the writers weren't trans the directors
weren't trans so it's
cis people's interpretation of what it
is to be trans and while i'm not going
to say it's inaccurate in any or all
these films that i've mentioned or that
i'm alluding to
i will say that there is a very strong
tendency by focusing on the transition
itself
to focus on the pain
and the problems in our lives
that come from that
whether it be
something like the danish girl where
lily literally died
trying to be
who she was
and
the film is largely about showing
the pain
of a male existence and using that as a
way to justify why
she took this chance or whether it be
something like boys don't cry
where
during the film brandon is largely in a
state of euphoria
about himself
it's still about the pain that's caused
when other people around him realize he
is trans similarly with
transamerica at the time that story
starts the league character has already
had her transition but it's about the
ripple effects and
the pain
caused by that
now basically any story is going to have
conflict and going to have characters
going through something that is painful
be it physical or emotional that's very
standard for any story but because the
transition itself is front and center
that means that these keeping depictions
of
trans-equaling
pain of some kind
physical pain dysphoric pain
pain of rejection from family
and
the prominence
of trans existence as pain
in narrative
i do feel at this point is becoming
legitimately harmful
while all the trans characters who are
supporting characters are helping to
counterbalance this because they don't
necessarily have to put their transition
front and center and are allowed to
simply be something else and just exist
as trans that certainly helps
but again every time we put the focus on
a trans person
look at the pain of being trans and like
i do understand that part of the reason
that pain has been put front and center
as a trans narrative is partly because
of the ways in which the trans community
itself has pushed for an understanding
there is a reason why there has been
historically and in
certain circles there still is such an
emphasis on dysphoria
because in trying to get cisgender
people who don't understand what it
feels like to be trans and it's not easy
for us to explain because there isn't
anything that you experience that we can
equate it to
linking it to
we are in pain because we're in the
wrong body
that was a way to
simplify and boil it down to something
that
was easier to push for
that was
well
it was transmedicalization
now the medicalizing of trans as a
concept the idea that only people who
have actually had surgery or
or who are on hormones or who have
dysphoria are the only people who are
legitimately trans and everyone else is
some kind of poser transtrender or
whatever is a harmful hurtful deplorable
narrative
but the initial pushing forward of
the pain and the dysphoria as a medical
concern
did
serve a purpose at one point
because that was something that we could
hopefully
get people who were not trans to
understand and if they treated it as a
medical condition with a medical
solution i.e hormones and or surgery
that was a start
but
that did unfortunately
put the pain of being trans front and
center
and did it for so long and so
effectively
that you see lots of people
when they start to question their own
gender
they fear the pain
that that life will bring
you see parents of trans kids
worried about the pain
that that existence will cause for them
you see them
focusing on the idea of their child
undergoing surgery this is a huge part
of the narrative pushing anti-trans
agendas the idea of they're trying to
give our kids these surgeries and
there's this focus on the medicalization
because there's this focus on the pain
and putting
trans pain
as
the forefront
of trans stories
in media
is feeding into that
because being trans
should not be defined by pain
and that is not to negate the pain of
any trans person
if you experience
severe dysphoria if it was only
alleviated by hormones and or by surgery
that is valid
that's also not me
i can't pretend to fully understand what
that's like
but
that is not the only thing that being
trans is
and i know it can be hard for some
people who feel like they have gone
through hell
to live as themselves
to hear people like me say okay but you
don't have to go through that to be
trans
i do understand that some of you did go
through that
but
those of us who didn't
are still trans
and again focusing
on the pain
be it something that political forces
focus on
the community itself focuses on
or media focuses on
you do that for too long
and that's what you frame being trans as
and that also
is not helping
and then
there's the offshoot of that i saved
this for the end because this is by far
not the main point i wanted to dwell on
partially because i've talked to this to
certain degrees before but this is
another element to it
and that is
the casting of cisgender people in trans
roles
as i said i've talked about it before
repeatedly but i feel like that's the
most relevant video if you don't
understand my basic premise but making
it as simple as i can
at this particular point in time
transgender people actors in particular
have a hard time getting roles at all
they are virtually never cast as cis
people and yet cis people are frequently
cast as trans people so trans people
can't even get casters themselves and
they don't get cast as anything else and
there is also the issue that casting a
cisgender person as a trans character
especially if the cisgender actor
their gender matches the gender that the
character transitioned out of instead of
into so in other words when you have a
man play a trans woman or a woman play a
trans man it contributes to the general
public perception that trans people are
really underneath whatever presentation
they give still the gender they were
assigned at birth and they're just
pretending because that's what the
actors are doing
it's not an intentional thing but it is
a persistent undercurrent that results
from that casting
here's why i bring it up again even
though i don't want to dwell on any of
the points you just made check out the
other video or other ones that i've made
on the topic since
the reason i bring it up again
is because i
at this point
the most common
thing i see brought up
trying to argue for the validity of
casting cisgender actors as transgender
characters
at least that gets deployed in good
faith because there's a ton of bad faith
versions the most common one being
directors they can be whatever you got
to insist we only cast aliens as alien
kids like all that's bad faith all of
that is bad faith and it's nonsense and
it is not actually engaging with any
point that i ever make it's
it is a thought-terminating cliche
but in terms of good faith concerns
the one that i see at this point
asks the following
wouldn't it be dysphoric for a trans
actor to play a pre-transition version
of that character isn't it a bad thing
to put an actor through that kind of
pain that's thing one
thing two
would it be believable would we be able
to pull off
believing the trans person as
the cisgender part of the story first
thing about both of these
it assumes that there has to be a
cisgender part of the story
and i think that's an offshoot of the
fact that this is the story that keeps
being told as the trans story
i've literally had comments be it here
on tik tok wherever i talk about this
where people present
concerns or questions that start from a
base assumption
that a trans story is going to deal with
a pre-transition period for that person
they assume that going in which
why wouldn't they assume that that's the
only kind of story that gets told
but let's actually address these two
things first one
the issue of
dysphoria
and again i do think
while this can be deployed in bad faith
any
valid argument can be deployed in bad
faith but i have seen it as a legitimate
concern from people
that
they would not want
a trans actor to
be put through a painful situation of
having to portray
something that isn't their gender
a couple of things about that
first is dysphoria is
incredibly personal
how severe it is
what sets it off
will vary wildly
from person to person
and while i do not doubt
there would be
some trans actors who would not be
comfortable portraying
the gender that they transitioned out of
i guarantee you that there's others who
would be who would be okay with it would
it be the most comfortable thing in the
world no not necessarily but actors
are frequently
asked to do things that are
uncomfortable i don't mean dangerous i'm
not talking about hazardous onset
conditions but
not trying to big up my own horn as a
pick up my own horn toot my own horn big
up myself mixing metaphors as an actor
um
but i got to be in a play
several years ago where i played a
character who was
deeply depressed and suicidal
and that was
very uncomfortable
like it left me in a bad place for a
little while playing that part but i
still volunteer because i wanted to do
it and i'm happy that i did it and i'm
proud of the work i did
when i performed that character on stage
but it was still uncomfortable
or if you want something more
recent just this year
in a fan audio adventure for doctor who
i did voice work
as a cis male character
and i was fine to do that
so while yes there will undoubtedly be
some trans people who would not be
comfortable portraying the gender that
they transitioned out of in their own
real life
there will be others who are okay with
that or at least okay enough with it to
be willing to take on the part
and to use that as a reason to just well
we can't cast trans person because of
this we have to cast a cis person no you
don't
maybe you have to look a little harder
to find the trans person who will be
good for the part and is comfortable
with that
but look
don't use it as an excuse to not look
and again this is actually an outcome
and a consequence of centering pain
as the central narrative of what it
means to be trans even people who are
trying to be allies
are
issuing concerns that would block trans
people trans performers from
opportunities because they are so
worried about pain and dysphoria because
that has become our entire
story
as for the other thing that one's really
easy anyone who says to me well
you know how would the trans person
portray you know the cis part of their
life well two things about that first is
being trans is not the same thing as
having had a transsexual operation and
actually having medical intervention to
change your gender
i have not had surgery i don't plan to
have surgery ever i am on hormones but
you can be trans while being on hormones
trans is who you are not necessarily all
the steps you have or plan to take to
best express that if you are able and
happy to fully express your sense of
gender
without hormones
without
surgery
you are just as trans as anybody else so
there's the first thing
uh
and then the second thing is well what
if they actually have had hormones or
surgeries or whatever how would you deal
with that well same reason same way you
deal with that in the other direction
same way you get the cis actors to look
trans the magic of hollywood makeup and
prosthetics
there's these weirdly
worded and overly
thought over and overly complicated
questions
that are very straightforward well what
if the actor's not comfortable with this
get a different actor
but but won't all trans people be like
no
well how do we make them look cis make
up
same way you make a cis person look
trans
and like i said this part of it was not
really the point
however i'd be lying if i didn't say
that some comments that i've seen about
this part of the topic
isn't why i wanted to talk about this
thing as a whole
right now the thing that that i want to
see more than anything
even more than seeing
trans actors play trans characters and
not see cis actors played in ortho i do
want that is to have
trans creators
being the ones telling these stories
i mentioned it in a short i did a week
or two back
right now these stories are being told
being written by being approved by in
the studios being directed by and being
acted in front of a screen by cisgender
people
our stories
are not in our own hands
and
funnily enough
more often than not when you get trans
creators even when they are telling
trans stories
it's usually about
a lot more than just being trans
you can just look at the wachowskis for
a primary example of that because if you
didn't realize the matrix is a trans
narrative or heck skip that just go to
sense8 and
not only is there a trans character in
there with as much prominence as any of
the other characters it being an
ensemble but the very nature of what
that story is functions in many ways as
a trans allegory just on premise
they can make it about being trans
without telling the standard trans
story
which is something that cisgender
creators can't seem to get past
and it's a story that's now been told
even if you think it's a story that's
been told well i would argue it's a
story that we don't need to keep telling
it's time to move on
it's time to show that being trans
is more than just the transition
that we are not defined by this one
aspect of who we are and that this one
aspect of who we are is not
necessarily defined as being
pain
those are my thoughts
on the state of
trans narratives in film
what do you think about this
whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it
like share subscribe i've got a patreon
that is how i pay my bills and it's what
enables me to
be able to have these conversations with
you as regularly as i do
so
i hope you'll consider supporting me or
becoming a channel member if you want to
go that way
i'm not going to put massive pressure on
you though
because the thing i really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey if you're sticking around through
the credits might as well hear some
names read out my patreon helps support
this and in particular i want to thank
raven mcbain bookworm mj tracy scrabbit
vincent paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz
edelen robin moore rosholtz shayla
gourlay wanna hear me mispronounce your
name check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]